this is the story of Magneto ripping the
adamantium out of Wolverine it's amazing
I'm pretty sure we talked about this in
our Onslaught Saga video but I don't
think we actually covered it but this
opens up with the X-Men discussing the
aftermath of Magneto having attacked the
world with an electromagnetic pulse
taking down every form of Technology
with the exception of the X-Men because
they power their base using alien
technology now why did Magneto EMP the
world okay so in the events leading up
to this what Magneto did is he launched
an orbital space station called Avalon
and this was designed to be a safe haven
for the mutant population for those of
you guys who ever watched X-Men the
Animated Series and you saw the two-part
episode Sanctuary those episodes were
based off of this but the concern that
Humanity had with Magneto doing this is
that it was not something done out of
Peace it wasn't done as a way to just
kind of live in isolation he was
effectively building an army at least
that's how Humanity saw it so the United
Nations security Council ended up
launching what was called the MC keto
protocols which was quite literally a
series of satellites that orbited the
world and created a kind of
electromagnetic mesh that would
effectively keep Magneto from being able
to use its powers such as it was it
didn't work and he took out the entire
satellite system with an EMP which also
affected Earth now the Fallout to this
is crazy because Cyclops literally
starts talking about what's going on
right like Rogue asked the question how
bad is it like how bad was this EMP and
the response to Cyclops is we can't
really know for certain he says but what
we do know from like the garbled static
that we have access to is that it's
incredibly bad plane crashes medical
equipment failure the whole nine yards
thousands and possibly even hundreds of
thousands of people have already died
let alone all the other people who will
die due to a lack of resources due to
overheating any number of things right
the inability to access food whatever
the case happens to be Magneto may have
quite possibly killed the world and so
in response to this Professor Xavier
says we have to basically go make a move
we have to go to Avalon and we have to
respond to Magneto now the intention
here of Xavier is to do it in his
non-peaceful of a way as possible but do
not misunderstand the circumstance
they're basically in the middle of what
is why all standards a measurement of
War it's Magneto having Waze war against
humanity or Humanity waging it against
him whichever side you decide to go with
but what Xavier does here is he actually
Dawns a Shia exoskeleton now we don't
have to go into like the nature of the
shiar just understand that they are an
extraterrestrial race that the X-Men are
very close to but their technology is
incredibly Advanced and so this suit not
only allows Professor Xavier to walk but
it actually offers itself as a kind of
battle armor the caveat to all of this
is that in order for him to use it he
has to exert an immense amount of
telepathic power so much so that he
needs Jean Gray of the X-Men to go with
him he does have a plan on how to handle
Magneto but he can't simply do what on
his own the other part of this is that
once they get there they're gonna have
to contend with the acolytes what are
the acolytes so the acolytes are
basically Magneto's own cult if you want
to call it that you have Exodus you've
got Fabian Cortez but they're
exceedingly capable mutants Exodus is
Far and Away the most powerful out of
all of them and he's actually more
powerful than Magneto but he doesn't
really care about levels of power he's
more of just a devout follower of
Magneto's teachings that like mutants
should rise above humanity and so the
result of this is that Xavier takes not
only Gene he takes Wolverine Gambit and
then Rogue and Quicksilver so the team's
pretty capable and more than enough to
handle virtually anybody out there
within the superhero or even super
villain Community now the big concern
that everybody has here is twofold the
first is that this team seems pretty
small if they're going to board a space
station that houses Magneto and his own
followers and the concern by storm and
cyclops is that these guys when get
eradicated pretty fast fortunately
Xavier does have an ace of his sleeve
but the other part of this is that while
Xavier doesn't tend to go in with like a
peaceful motivation something's gonna
happen right their concern is like
things are going to go sideways super
fast and Xavier's hand is going to be
revealed and he's gonna have to do
something that he doesn't want to have
to do but such as it is Bishop Jubilee
Iceman Archangel like they all basically
have to stay behind so you're not going
to see them for the rest of the story
The thing about this though is that once
they board the space station the first
thing they do is they basically Force
activate the teleporters and get Exodus
out of there as fast as they can and
that's the smartest thing to do because
the power of Exodus this guy's an Omega
Level telepath he is Way Beyond
professor Charles Xavier and while Jean
Gray is powerful she doesn't have the
Phoenix Force anymore so she's not
nearly as powerful as she used to be
Exodus would thrash both of them and be
home in time for cornflakes so that's
why they got to get him out there as
quick as they can the other part of this
is of course just kind of ancillary
forces that happen to be around there
and they take those guys out quite
readily right there's not a great big
huge deal but then everything goes
sideways just like the other X-Men
thought it would as soon as Magneto
shows up here because once Exodus is
teleported away Magneto realizes
something's going on and the X-Men would
be the only ones Brazen enough to launch
a strike against Magneto directly The
Avengers wouldn't do it and the
Fantastic Four certainly wouldn't but
the X-Men absolutely would not only that
what's so interesting about this is
Magneto when he stands on the face of
the X-Men his response is why are you
trying to stop me I'm literally trying
to create a safe haven for the whole of
the mutant population what you're doing
here is you're basically telling me yes
Magneto I understand you're trying to
create a place where mutants can exist
in peace but that shouldn't happen
because we should have a peaceful
coexistence between humans and mutants
but the response of Magneto is if
Humanity wanted to live peacefully among
the mutant population they would have
done it by now the fact that they
haven't shows that they don't want to
now here's the big thing about this
while Magneto does have his helmet on
which basically blocks out any form of
telepathic attack the hope of Xavier is
that with his powers combined with Gene
it would be enough to overwhelm it that
once the other X-Men are able to kind of
offer as a distraction potentially one
of them could get the helmet off and in
turn they can just start forcing all
these psychic projections into the mind
of Magneto and so that's why you see the
two of them combining their power
together and they immediately launch a
psychic attack on Magneto despite the
helmet that he has under any normal
circumstance that would never happen
right but given the fact that their
powers are combined it basically allows
it to take place and this from Magneto's
perspective is a grave Injustice because
they start blasting him with these
psychic images of his own history his
youngest daughter Anya burning to death
in a house the whole ordeal that he
experienced in World War II the most
horrific moments of of his life and the
Hope in doing this is that it would
force him into a state where he just
kind of curls up in a fetal position not
necessarily giving up but just being
overwhelmed by the entire experience the
exact opposite happens and Magneto loses
it this guy goes all the way off right
he literally says like you surprise me
Charles I thought such manipulations are
boring to you you ask me why I do what I
do and I ask in return how can you not
and so the other X-Men jump in where
they can when they can Gambit is taken
out like that Rogue attacks Magneto but
she's taken out almost just as fast but
before anything can really happen to
Rogue Quicksilver steps in now the
significance of the fight between
Quicksilver and Magneto is really based
more on the history that the two of them
have together as opposed to like the
significance of this moment in the sense
that Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch being
the children of Magneto is one of those
weird things that Marvel kind of screws
around with but at this point in time
they were his kids they were initially
brought on to the Brotherhood of evil
mutants magnet own kind of anti-x-men
team but then left relatively quickly
and have kind of been his enemy more or
less ever since and that's why he says
things like time and time again upon
learning you and your sister Wanda the
Scarlet Witch were my children the
children of my beloved lost Magna you
have been offered the opportunity to
stand by my side as was your right as
would have been my joy and so this is
all predicated on the idea that like
they rejected his philosophies so that's
why this sort of conflict between the
two of them is really significant here
right it's just a father and son
basically fighting over the things
they've had to contend with before but
of course Magneto overpowers Quicksilver
and that's when Wolverine steps in now
here's the funny thing about this right
like Wolverine launches an attack
against Magneto and he kind of freaks
out the reason why that happened is
because in The Uncanny X-Men comic
leading up to this literally the story
that happened right before this
Wolverine attacked Magneto and almost
killed him not only that Magneto is well
aware of the ferocity of Wolverine in
the sense that there's two forms when it
comes to his character comic book
readers already know about this so this
is for like the non-comic book reader
but you've got Wolverine who's just
really angry and he attacks and that's
it then you've got Berserker Wolverine
woe batai the poor soul that has to face
that guy because that's when he loses
all semblance of self-control and falls
into this animalistic State and just
starts killing everything in his path
it's why like when Wolverine goes into a
Berserker rage people flee they
absolutely run because at the end of the
day he will not discern between teammate
and enemy he will kill any and everybody
and so where he does get the attack on
Magneto in this moment when Magneto's at
his most vulnerable that's when Xavier
tells Gene we have to attack him like we
have to overcome him as fast as we can
but the responsive genus hesitation
right she's like look I mean look how
weak he is like we don't have to like
launch a psychic attack and potentially
destroy this guy's mind we already have
him on the ropes all we have to do is
overpower him but in this moment when
Gene teams pleading her case Magneto is
like enough like I have had absolutely
enough I'm trying to make a safe haven
for the mutant population you guys show
up here with your righteous causes and
your stupid little speeches trying to
tell me about how I'm wrong you're
literally getting in the way of progress
so if you thought I was the bad guy
before if you thought you've seen me
pissed off before wait till I show you
what's about to happen next and he
snatches Wolverine up using his powers
and rips the adamantium right out of his
body and everyone is horrified because
they've never seen this side of Magneto
before they've never seen him go to this
extreme this guy is driven by just pure
rage but more so than that he's making a
point like he's making an absolute point
if you get in my way I will destroy you
I'll go after you and anybody you've
ever met Wolverine is just an example
here right like the most horrific thing
that I could do to this guy is rip the
adamantium out of his body as you you
all watch him writhing in pain but not
making a single sound now the funny
thing about this is that this is
designed to demoralize it's designed to
demoralize the X-Men and to basically
send them more or less fleeing to
retreat and say there's nothing we can
do here instead the opposite happens
with Xavier that he realizes there is no
stopping Magneto here there's no
reasoning with him there's no bargaining
with him this guy committed arguably the
most egregious act that he's ever
committed against any Mutant in
existence in Marvel Comics history in
this moment and so Xavier realizes
there's only one thing that can be done
with Magneto's helmet basically ripped
off of his head or at least knocked off
of his head Xavier just starts blasting
Magneto with all these horrific psychic
images and where Magneto is able to
overcome it momentarily Xavier literally
lashes out out of anger and shuts
Magneto's mind down like puts him in a
catatonic State just takes his mind away
and that's it right he's like literally
Magneto it's game over like done so for
his character and it's really to a shock
to everybody because Xavier just loses
control here here's what's so crazy
about this two major things happen as a
result of this whole fight this battle
between Xavier and Magneto the first is
that Xavier is actually absorbing a
portion of Magneto's mind he just
doesn't realize it this kicks off the
onslaught Saga the second thing that
happens is that Wolverine goes forward
as feral Wolverine that this is the
point in Marvel Comics when we learn for
the first time he has bone claws that
his adamantium claws were bonded to his
existing bone it wasn't something that
just came into existence once adamantium
was bonded to his body so if you guys
are interested in the onslaught Saga
which is amazing he's a ridiculously op
villain make sure you check out this
video here and if you guys want me to
cover the Pharaoh Wolverine series let
me know down in the comments thank you
all for watching and I will catch you
all later peace